attenzione lo fece la visione in 3 2
perché noi quando il fondo regista mi
dice siamo persone serie
i ragazzi facciamo su pizza pizza per 10
minuti 3 contenti lasciate mi piace oggi
facciamo le lingue lavori siamo esperti
di ritmo e sono dimora in questo gioco
si attivi un buon simona un sacco questa
misura sbagliata o verità nessuno ok se
le facciamo le cose sono diverse tra di
loro quando mai lo si capisce un cazzo
dove che sei italiano l'anno precedente
si sentono le lunghe ti sanchez è anche
il disco spagnolo sono scomposte parole
[Musica]
italiano alle nazioni
considerato che coreano loro fede nei
diritti umani la paura
letture di celina dell'uguaglianza dei
diritti dell'uomo nero vaticana subisce
cosa contro vicende camerun dai era già
dopo un'altra italiana
questi soldi ma nel etimologico bengali
è una fusione tra ben ali
[Applauso]
gli occhi a kabul quella stessa in fiera
di me lo sono guadagnato è riuscito a
parlare particolare per quello tra sfera
magica il vettore per adulti anche un po
dolorosa con tanto però alla fine si fa
vedere particolare tra rimangono un
personaggio particolare di de bahia de
mori arabe soci maggio 9 corretta
va bè ragazzi dire grazie
direi che possiamo concludere i ragazzi
perché io vi sia piaciuto è un prodotto
distinguono quelle di cavani non
sappiamo mangano francese vicina
riciclabile scontiamo beh insomma quei
ragazzi privi di preciso cosa è il sogno
di cemento mi piaceva stata anche le
gare di dolore tecnici
[Musica]
alpiq
noi
[Musica]
ap